lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
graficar algunas rectas usando las
intersecciones con el eje x y el eje y
de la recta para empezar una recta está
definida por dos puntos 52 puntos
los gráficas los conectas con una recta
y la extiendes en ambas direcciones vas
a ver graficado esa línea recta y lo que
voy a hacer en este vídeo los dos puntos
que voy a elegir son las intersecciones
intersecciones de la recta y hay dos de
ellas intersección con x e intersección
con jeff estas corresponden a los puntos
donde la recta intersecta el eje x y el
eje y para asegurarnos que sabemos a qué
nos estamos refiriendo esta de aquí en
mi papel gráfico es el eje x se extiende
en ambas direcciones este es mi eje x
mientras que esta de aquí justo a la
mitad yendo de arriba hacia abajo es mi
eje que este que tenemos aquí es
entonces mi eje
creo que no se ve bien ahí abajo este de
aquí es el eje que deja de mostrarte
entonces que quiere decir intersecciones
con equis y hagamos el inciso a inciso a
déjame hacerlo con otro color inciso a
tenemos la ecuación que es igual a 2 x +
3 veamos qué pasa cuando x es igual a 0
cuando x es igual a 0 la ecuación
resulta de igual a igual a 2 x 0
+ 3 2 por 0 0 por lo cual es igual a 0 3
hoy es igual a 3 entonces el punto x es
igual a 0 y es igual a 3 que satisface
esta ecuación se ubica sobre la recta
definida por esta ecuación tenemos así
el punto 0 3 vamos a graficar lo este es
el punto 0,3 se observa que este punto
corresponde a x igual a 0 pero se ubica
sobre el eje y es por eso que le
llamamos intersección con qué ocurre
cuando x es igual a 0 pero se llama
intersección con ye por que se ubica
sobre el eje y es el punto donde la
recta intersecta el eje y hagamos ahora
lo mismo para el eje x fijemos ya igual
a 0 y que tenemos 0 es igual a 2 x + 3
restamos 3 a ambos lados del lado
izquierdo nos queda menos 3 es igual a
2x dividimos entre 2 ambos lados por lo
cual resulta menos 3 medios es igual a x
x es igual a menos 3 medios o menos 1.5
tenemos entonces ahora el punto menos 3
medios
0 verdad este segundo caso es cuando y
es igual a 0
sabemos que esta pareja de valores xy
también satisface esta ecuación o que es
un punto que se ubica sobre la recta
entonces menos tres medios recuerda que
lo mismo que menos 1.5 con ye igual a
cero aquí lo tenemos y estamos ubicando
la intersección con el eje x
intersección con x ésta es la
intersección con x y si queremos dibujar
la línea conectamos estos dos puntos
conectamos estos puntos y extendemos la
línea en ambas direcciones hacia el
infinito en ambas direcciones
aquí tenemos entonces la gráfica de la
recta hagamos otro de estos no quiero
amontonar me así es que voy a borrar
esto
borro esto y aquí también vamos a borrar
esto siempre puedes ponerle pausa y
volver a ver esto déjame borrar esto de
aquí ops no debería haber hecho eso
bueno si se llegan a ver los ejes voy a
volverlos a trazar voy a redibujar el
eje x este de aquí es mi eje x y este de
aquí es mi eje y ahí lo tenemos
hagamos inciso b inciso b se ve
interesante entonces el inciso b es 6
por x 1 es igual a 2 por jay más 3
veamos qué sucede cuando x es igual a
cero cuando x es igual a cero el lado
izquierdo resulta 6 x 0 - 1 esto es 6 x
menos 1 y esto nos da menos 6 es igual a
déjame distribuir lo que tenemos del
lado derecho que sería 2 porque más 6 2
por 2 y 2 x 36 ahora restamos 6 a ambos
lados del lado izquierdo que nos resulta
12 y del lado derecho tenemos 2 y al
restar 6 este 6 es como si hubiéramos
pasado del lado izquierdo al restar 6 de
aquí esto desaparece y el restan 6 de
aquí obtenemos menos 12 dividiendo ambos
lados entre 2 que obtenemos del lado
izquierdo menos 6 y del lado derecho
entonces el primer punto que tenemos
sobre la línea es el punto cuando x es
igual a 0 y es igual a menos 6 aquí está
el punto 0.6 que corresponde a la
intersección con ye esa es la
intersección con jeff veamos ahora qué
pasa cuando hoy es igual a 0 cuando hoy
es igual a 0
vayamos a la ecuación original y veamos
qué sucede déjame escribir esto un
poquito diferente que es igual a 0 que
sucede sustituyendo aquí voy distribuir
primero esto 6 por x menos 6 va a ser
igual 2 x cuando es igual a cero este
término se cancela y me resultados por
36 esto va a ser igual a 6
si restamos 6 ambos lados o más bien
sumamos 6 ambos lados porque quiero
cancelar este menos 6 resulta 6 x del
lado izquierdo va a ser igual a 6 + 6 12
y obtenemos x dividiendo ambos lados
entre 6 obtenemos x es igual a 2 así que
la otra intersección es x igualados y es
igual a 0
aquí la tenemos x es igual a 2 y es
igual a 0 y ésta corresponde a la
intersección con x esa es entonces la
intersección con x y para dibujar la
recta conectamos estos puntos bueno no
está muy derecho pero ya tienen la idea
dos puntos definen una recta déjame
hacer otro de estos
voy a hacerlo por acá en este terreno de
acá arriba voy a hacer inciso de inciso
c tú lo puedes hacer como práctica
inciso de establece x + y es igual a 8
este ejemplo es realmente fácil cuando x
es igual a 0
puedes ver inmediatamente la ecuación
que ya es igual a 8 y cuando es igual a
0 casi casi que puedes tapar esto para
obtener x + 0 igual a 8 por lo cual x es
igual a 8 esto fue directo inmediato
tenemos entonces el punto cero 808 lo
tenemos por aquí
esta es la intersección con ye y también
tenemos el punto 80 esta es la
intersección con x ya podemos conectar
los puntos para que veamos nuestra recta
más o menos así
hagamos este problema por acá abajo en
la tienda de la esquina las fresas
cuestan tres dólares por libra y los
plátanos cuestan un dólar por libra
si tengo diez dólares para gastar tengo
diez dólares para gastar entre fresas y
plátanos dibujo una gráfica que muestre
las cantidades de cada una que puedo
comprar por exactamente diez dólares
bien voy a dibujar mis ejes o hacer
ciudad me que estén bien marcados
recuerda que este es el eje horizontal
de izquierda a derecha y para
entretenernos un rato en vez de llamarle
el eje x lo voy a llamar a este el eje
de las fresas este es el eje de las
fresas
mejor oa poner simplemente con la letra
f la letra f aquí lo voy a establecer
sea f igual a número de fresas número de
fresas y ya sabes por dónde va la cosa
entonces nuestro eje p va a ser número
de plátanos número de plátanos y ese va
a ser nuestro eje vertical déjame hacer
entonces nuestro eje vertical donde
vamos a registrar el número de plátanos
este va a ser el eje vertical con la p
designado por la letra p de plátanos p
de plátanos ok entonces las fresas
cuestan 3 dólares por libra aquí tenemos
un error porque no vamos a trabajar con
el número de fresas más bien es el
número de libras déjame corregirlo
libras de fresas y este de aquí es
libras de plátanos libras de plátanos
bien las fresas cuestan tres dólares por
libra y los plátanos un dólar por libra
entonces que tenemos
3 por el número de fresas o más bien el
número de libras de fresa recordemos más
1 por el número de libras de plátanos y
esto debe ser igual a 10 dólares que
tengo para gastar entonces tres por
nueve libras de fresas más el número de
libras de plátanos va a ser igual a 10
uno por b es igual a b y esto lo puede
escribir como 3 s b es igual a 10
hagamos la gráfica de esto primero
consideremos cuando uno compro fresas es
decir cuando el número de libras de
fresa es igual a cero que tenemos
entonces esta ecuación nos dice que 3 x
0 + p es igual a 10 este término se
cancela de donde obtenemos que p es
igual a 10 así que tenemos el punto
donde compró 0 libras de fresa y 10
libras de plátanos gráfica hemos lo si
no compro libras de fresas obtenemos 10
libras de plátanos este es el punto
veamos el otro caso donde
compro 0 libras de plátanos ve es igual
a 0 sustituyendo en la ecuación que
tenemos 3 veces el número de libras de
fresas + 0 libras de plátanos es igual a
este número se hace 0 y dividiendo ambos
lados entre 3 tenemos si no compro
plátanos puedo obtener 10 tercios de
libra de fresas o lo que es lo mismo 3
enteros un tercio tendremos entonces el
punto 3 enteros un tercio libras de
fresas coma 0 libras de plátanos 3
enteros un tercio libres de fresa 0
libras de plátanos y podemos conectar
los puntos para obtener la recta la
recta completa la voy a dibujar
únicamente en el primer cuadrante
no podemos tener plátanos negativos no
va a vender libras de plátanos y tampoco
puede tener fresas negativas no estamos
hablando de vender fresas solo puedo
comprar estas frutas este la cantidad
que estoy comprando vamos a conectar los
puntos y esto es muy bueno porque esta
línea nos muestra todas las
combinaciones de fresas y plátanos que
podemos comprar por ejemplo
este punto que tenemos aquí no sé si lo
tengo muy exacto pero si puedo comprar
cinco libras de plátanos parece que
puedo comprar ligeramente menos de dos
libras de fresas eso es lo que me dice
en cambio este punto de aquí si puedo
comprarte libras de fresas si puedo
comprar exactamente tres libras de
fresas puedo comprar una libra de
plátanos cada punto aquí representa una
combinación de fresas y plátanos que
puedo comprar por diez dólares